welcome to GameSpot's play for all we're
talking about Star Wars squadrons I am
rob joint here with Ian Frazer creative
director who better than to talk about
this upcoming game that I am trying to
distill my excitement the purpose of
this interview but I'm extremely excited
how're you doing Ian doing good doing
good it's good
coming in here toward the end of the
project and finally getting to actually
show it to people yeah definitely like
the reception's been been pretty
positive for the most mean I'm biased in
the sense that like I feel like I've
been dreaming of this game since I was
like 13 and I like had my cousin's show
me Return of the Jedi like Mon Calamari
ships move and how slowly they moved I
don't know I can get like super dorky
but like I watch Star Wars movies for
spaceships like awesome so this is
honestly a dream come true but I'm
biased so I'm curious to know why so
you're talking the wrong guy if you want
to know totally but like I was like you
know I'm not the only one you're not the
only one who is just like infatuated
with just Star Wars spaceships but like
why bring this game now to an audience
yeah I mean it's to some degree the
short answer is because we wanted to you
know we had a window time after the
team's coming off the battlefront to
another project as well and the team we
had a few people the team that have
played or worked on the space missions
specifically in Battlefront 2 and they
were out having a beer and shame just
like wouldn't be awesome if we go back
to like the 90s star wars flight games
just like make that happen again and
it's uh you know I I was super into into
pretty much all the stuff like games in
the 90s to to to very instead so soon I
heard about this like oh I gotta be in I
gotta work on this and say hey let's
take the genre that
and basically gone for 20 years yeah we
we want to do this and it's it's you
know like the biggest brand in the world
and we want to spend millions of dollars
doing it definitely you know you first
bring that up people I like but we got a
prototype up and running really fast and
I mean like the first one was like a
week every I don't we had a purchase
type of brewing the team was amazing and
so as soon as you could show it as soon
as I could play it they're like well
maybe this hasn't been around in a while
but it needs to be like it's a really
awesome experience and so just through
it through you build it they will come
we build a prototype and very quickly
within EA and then ultimately Lucasfilm
we've got a lot of excitement a lot of a
lot of energy around it so on that note
like you know and I know you didn't
directly work on like battlefront one
like 2016 and then the subsequent you
know about battlefront 2 but like
battlefront 2 kind of like stepped it up
with like a lot of the aerial combat
like do you have any thoughts on like
balancing with like you know a more
casual player because I'm getting at is
like again like a lot of those bow from
one games are like kind of level playing
field there's not like a direct
one-to-one role with like how you
control your starship like is a casual
player and a hardcore flight sim player
are they are they gonna meet well at the
end of the day well so what we've tried
to do and depending on if you're talking
about the single-player side of the game
or the multiplayer is I'm looking at
different answers we try to make a game
that's not exclusively for flights and
fans by any means you know we want we
wanted to be something that if you love
Star Wars and you want to fly an x-wing
TIE fighter by this game you're gonna
have a good time that's obviously a big
goal for us at the same time you know
you're not wrong that this game is it's
a crunchy ER game it's got a lot more
kind of moving parts to and it's
something that that has a relatively
high steel ceiling there's a range there
from I can fly a ship at all - I am
awesome so we try to do is first
obviously the single-player story has a
variety of difficulty modes and if
you're playing that on on the story mode
so the easier setting we're trying to
make it so that you know you just want
to have the ace pilot experience and you
want to hop into Star Wars and fly these
ships and playing a playthrough cool
story and experience that and pictures
for a part of the time period of the
setting that hasn't been seen a whole
lot that's awesome so let's say you've
done that like I want to keep playing
well you can play the fleet battles mode
it doesn't actually have to be played
competitively you can play that either
with your friends in a co-op setting
against AI or just by yourself with AI
against stay away and you can do that
for you know and to finish them across
all the different maps everything and
that has its own difficulty modes so if
you play that on the easier setting
that's something that if you're not the
best pilot who ever piloted is something
you can still enjoy for though for the
long haul the harder mode is
deliberately harder once you get into
PvP there's the dogfights which are kind
of your core space combat shoot the
other ship whoever gets the most kills
wins for both that and the full PvP
fleet battles like all humans against
all humans it's it's really matchmaking
is the answer right like we do placement
a certain number of placement matches so
when you start playing we're kind of
trying to evaluate where you stand skill
wise and after those that handful of
placement matches if you're on the lower
end of skill we're not gonna put you up
against the the amazing super flattest
rig in the VR you know but if you want
that competitive experience fleet
battles are ranked and you've not you're
both the ranking and matchmaking you're
going to climb up those ranks on fleet
battles because those sounds like really
fun scenarios the gameplay trailer that
we saw like kind of insinuated you know
there are obviously different types of
fighters and spaceships so you have your
fighters you have your generic ones
interceptors like the a-wing and then
and ty interceptor and then like I guess
more of a heavy bomber I'm sure you have
other classes down the road but like how
does like squad customization work
before you enter a match like can you
speak on anything like that yeah I guess
we don't go much into that in the video
so before you go into a match whether
it's a dogfight or a fleet battle you're
gonna be in a briefing room and so it's
kind of like you're inside your flagship
before the fight you can be in the
briefing room or you can go in the
hangar the hangar is there to customize
your ship and to kind of look at it up
close you kind of walk around it like
like just different spots around it's
you ship for customizing your
your ship there's that the briefing room
is the social space so your avatar is
your pilot everybody else's are gathered
we're on that hallow briefing table you
get information about the you like a
kind of an overview of how the mode
works just like by clicking on the table
or you can look at your friends talk to
them either with voice over IP or with
just a comm menu you can open up and has
some canned things you can say which are
tied to the voice back to choice your
character it's one of the customizable
things and so it's the ideas your
planning happens there and you've got of
course a UI that tells you everybody
took this ship and these kind of those
components and what we often see like
when we do team play tests internally is
the different strategies emerging there
so whether it's before they even get to
the the briefing room where they do it
in the briefing room you know you'll
have folks going well okay if we went
all I own this time you know what are
the downsides for that what what kind of
pros and cons we get for for that
strategy and maybe it works maybe it
doesn't they try something else the next
time but that that room is really where
that happens both the social aspect of
just doing emotes and having some fun
but also okay what's everybody taking
this time this is mon mothma
they're just like kind of orchestrating
the pre-brief so I can't speak specific
characters I can share both
single-player and PvP have that briefing
room and in single-player the briefing
room is for briefings so you will have
characters outlining your mission to
come in the briefing right again the
gameplay trailer was a lot of it was
first-person you know I've I've been
obsessed with like battlefield games for
that matter with like you know switching
between camera perspectives
is there a third-person camera
perspective for this game is it's just
strictly first-person the whole game is
designed from the ground up to be
first-person all the way through now if
you're in spectator mode you're
observing there's third-person cameras
available there but in actual play it's
always first-person partially because
we've both built this game around the
idea of you are the pilot like really
trying to immerse you in that role as
much as humanly possible and a big part
of how we do that is you could probably
tell in the gameplay video is those
cockpits like all the diegetic
information that's built into the hood
so like you can turn off all the game
layer UI if you want and entirely rely
on your instruments I mean really we
want that to be the core experience and
then from just like a practical design
standpoint if we had the
person suddenly there's a there's always
inherently a competitive advantage to
third person because you have more more
peripheral view and so suddenly it's
like well okay the way that we intend
the player experience the game
no one will because you're going to have
a competitive advantage and playing it
the other way so it no we're gonna we're
gonna focus this game and what we want
that core experience to be just being a
pilot hands on the controls flying the
ship sick
on that note then one of the things I've
always experienced with like Tie
Fighters
it's like it's the death that there's
definitely that but like you know you
having played a lot of flight sim games
first-person like you know there's you
you have a comparison as you mentioned
peripherals right like in a weighing
canopy is pretty luxurious right like
you can you can see a lot around you do
you have any balancing or like solutions
to like you just you know maybe that's
why the Empire died well like not even
just peripheral vision but like you know
like the cockpit and then deny on wings
you just can't see around them are there
any solutions to that cuz I've just I've
always thought about that as a problem
it's funny so when we started I was more
worried about I was worried about that
from a faction standpoint and I was
worried about you know VR and 2d because
we always intended them to play together
even before we had full cross play which
now we have which is awesome and so
we're worried like are the rebels gonna
have an advantage because you know
behaving visibility as you say is it
good VR is gonna have advantage because
those players can see more and what we
found is it's kind of funny so we
started the project and went back and I
replay it a lot of classic games and we
played all of x-wing and Thai fighter
and the xvt balanced power campaign and
I looked up that and also gain facts for
the old games like reroutes watcher next
week and so on from the time and there's
a question from x-wing vs. TIE fighter
the game fact that someone asked which
is hey you know what was the advantage
disadvantage in factions or something to
that effect and the answer then in 1977
was well you have a lot more stuff are
sorry lot less stuff to deal with in
Imperial ship and that is in its sense
and advantage and I've actually found
that to be shockingly true in our game
is that if you're flying I'll just
straight up x-wing TIE fighter
comparison the TIE fighter doesn't have
shields which you don't have shields
which is a downside right but it also
means you don't need to manage shields
it's one less thing to kind of have in
your head one less thing you need to
manage so there's less it's kind of head
space required for that and your
visibility is focused very much forward
because you don't have that wide view
you have your your sensor like a radar
so you know you don't know where
everything is it's you may not see it
but then they could I because of that
view what we found that the fact that it
focuses you forward yeah actually for a
lot of players makes the game easier for
them because there's just less stuff to
sort of take in and it's the same with
2d versus we are like like I personally
prefer V Ark is just the immersion
factor I love it
but being play VR is more like being a
real pilot being a real pilot is hard
you know so being aware of all your
instrumentation the physical space is
very challenging for many players so we
found that that 2d and/or being an
imperial ship the kind of counterbalance
of what you're losing is what you're
gaining in terms of focus yeah that
makes a lot of sense you know it super
rambley answer I know but no no that was
no that was great you just maybe remind
reminisce 2016 I went and saw the scare
update DLC for bow from one and the
component of the presentation was the
x-wing VR mission and I just wanted to
throw in there that like that was the
takeaway where I was like holy God like
that was such a great like test case
where I just walked away I remember
thinking like more of this the idea of
sitting in a seat with VR headset is
just perfect for flight Sims and this is
why this game I think is gonna latch
with people so I just wanted to say that
yeah thank you I mean honestly up for a
lot of us it's that same kind of
thinking rug one VR criterion did an
outstanding job with that it's a master
race and you play it you're like okay
now I want a whole game that's this
brand you know it's not one-to-one we do
a lot more than just being that but
longer but it's hard a lot of it is you
know gonna have that whole experience
and it's actually also kudos
tima criterion because they implemented
the are and frostbite if they hadn't
done one this would have been a whole
lot harder for us to build so it's the
oldest standing on the shoulders of
giants thing very much big part of the
outstanding work that team did it just
came possible yeah on that note like is
there any like you know it sounds like
criterion did a lot of the you know the
test work here are there any other like
polls or you know jumping-off points
with like battlefront with that matter
that your team has been looking into I'd
say more experientially because you know
I was on battlefront myself but a lot of
the team was you know came over on that
project so I think working with Star
Wars you know learning what works and
what doesn't work has definitely been a
help to us you know everything we build
is new so it's not like just take the
x-wing for bowel friendly now everything
we've built for the game is actually
from scratch for a whole bunch of
different reasons but the experience I
think has benefited us and the
technology to VR is a specific example
where that going into the engine may
definitely hit our lives easier one of
the things I noticed in the trailer was
having washes for five times you know a
lot of the I would say problems with
with dogfighting in general is that
you're sometimes potentially just doing
the definitely the death loop I saw a
move that was like an air breaking a
manual air breaking or like a mid-flight
like repositioning strafing that was a
drift yeah did the drift is that
recalling anything yeah okay well that
was pretty III can guess from kind of
where you're starting there yeah you're
you're not wrong so so there's a few
reasons we have that ability in the game
and one of them is cuz you're right
every flight game Under the Sun always
struggles with what we totally call the
death loop you're chasing me and I'm
chasing you and round we go so we have a
few ways to let people get out of that
one is where you sit on the throttle
with your dead center in the throttle we
call the sweet spot that's where your
turn rate is best on top of that putting
full power in engines or just more power
in engines also makes you more
maneuverable so first is like okay do
you do that give you a bit of advantage
and we'll assume it's to more or less
evenly matched ships here in terms of
their ability to turn okay well let's
say that there are an equally good pilot
they also did those things all right
we're right back to the death
what this drift thing does is whenever
you're whenever you max any of the
systems so lasers engines or shields
assuming leadership and shields there's
something extra special it does if the
system is fully maxed out in the case of
engines it builds a boost charge which
lets you Juke goes crazy fast for a
short duration you can't steer very well
what you're doing it right but you can
get uniform point A to point B quite
quickly so what that does is it means
that if you've maxed out engines while
you're in that loop you can choose
whenever you want to to do that boost
and go off whatever angle you want to do
and then we had that working but then we
found well okay whoever did that would
lose because they would you know chased
off so then we allowed the ability to
drift so you start boosting the moment
you do you can kind of cut your engine
and then you can freeform turnarounds
you can you can do things like shoot
missiles off your tail you can go after
the guy who's just come after you or so
far are quickly skill players will do
this they'll max the boost charge they a
lot of it do a little boost cut it off
per 90 degrees do another little boost
and do these kind of wild
evasive maneuvers so it's among other
things it's tool to let people solve
that problem to get out of yes it
reminds me of no it's it was really it
maybe excited because that's definitely
something you struggle with right like
you don't want to get into those
situations where you're just your hands
are tense and it's just like okay I give
up like I got to do something abrasive
or you know lack thereof and then I'm in
their crosshairs I'm also just fun like
I like to go you know the bridge of the
stardestroyer it's got a kind of a knack
underneath it yes love to fly under that
and then do the drift to kind of loop
around over the top it's just really
kind of this really satisfying
yeah right so like that's the other
slight question I have is I would
imagine a lot of these maps are gonna
have a lot of like obstacles and things
in the mix you know to compensate as
well to avoid one of the best things I
love about flight Sims is when you have
that opportunity like hit a canyon or
hit hit an obstacle and and make just to
get someone out of your sight just so
you can like make some sporadic so it
sounds like you have that coverage as
well yeah based on the trailer yeah yeah
it varies per map how we do that and how
much we do that but yes right
yeah progression you know it's great to
hear you no no microtransactions it
sounds like little so can you kind of
share light on just progression in
general like like how are we customizing
and implementing ship loadouts as we go
yeah the short version is as you play as
you get into the competitive play you're
earning two currencies one of those
currencies is called glory and that's
what you're using to unlock various
cosmetics in the game to make your pilot
look cooler sound cooler your ships look
Aleutian cooler and that's all cosmetic
all the time the other currency you
unlock also just by playing they're just
they're are locked in different ways
like this one might be from a challenge
that one might be just levelling up that
you know different different sources but
you're earning by playing is a long long
story short the other requisition you
use to unlock components for your ships
and that's both the passive things like
hull plating or a deflector shield or
the more active stuff like your your
weapon or your your missiles and mines
and that kind of thing and they're all
the mistress is clear in the video but
there are all orthogonal choices so
you're not buying the level 1 laser and
then the level 2 laser which is just
better it's well I want this laser I
want this other one that's rapid fire
shorter range burns through the energy
real fast that has it's useful in a
context it's not useful in every context
so you're always making these kind of
trade-offs it's it's more Protoss vs.
Zerg than number one versus level 2 in
terms of you know what what things I
want to take and where it gets cool is
it's not it's not a one I mean single
players of a single player but once you
come into PvP it's not one person versus
the world it's always a team of five
we've built everything actually
including a single player it's just that
they're gonna four people are AI
everything's built around that idea of
the tight-knit squadron and so in in PvP
it's not just what loadout are you
taking although yeah that matters but
what are your buddies taking you know
and how can you get synergies between
those things so like okay I've got the
tractor beam that's gonna hold him in
place for a couple seconds you know
she's got the Goliath missile which can
kick the crap out of them but it doesn't
track very well and those two things in
combination real dangerous a lot of team
coordination sounds like that's that's
really neat so final question here how
has your team been holding up with kovat
quarantine in
well I mean obviously it's challenging I
would prefer not to final a game during
a once in a century pandemic you know
all things being equal but the team the
team first of all I've been really
really impressed at how well EA and our
studio motive have handled the whole
thing like the immediate support the the
immediate support above all the team
every individual person being very you
know recognizing everybody's individual
personal needs getting hardware you're
shipped out to people they'll
practically do their jobs it's you know
I thought once it's work at home it's
gonna be a disaster but no actually it's
it's been it's been hard but I think
everybody's has made that turn really
quickly the company's been very
supportive and kind of pleased with the
results I guess not that I want to be
this way forever but I'm really
impressed with how the team has handled
it
that's great yeah I just wanted to ask
because you know we're all kind of
dealing with it right now and it's yes
it's it's a new wave of workflow yeah
yeah Thank You Ian so much for your time
and thank you guys for watching again
this is a games play for all we have
tons of more announcements down the road
so stay tuned and again Ian thank you so
much for joining us and best of luck
with awesome Star Wars squadrons thank
you thanks for having me and I hope you
love the game
[Music]
you
[Music]